de representantes los demócratas tienen
215 sillas aseguradas y los republicanos
196 hay 24 todavía en juego y los
demócratas necesitan 3 para llegar a la
mayoría que se requiere de 218 sillas en
cuanto al senado hay un empate entre 48
sillas que ya están aseguradas de los
demócratas y 48 de los senadores pero la
carrera al senado se va a definir en
enero porque una de las sillas la silla
de georgia pues tendrá una carrera
especial una carrera por su cuenta en
enero entre david por you y jon o soft
es importante la carrera al senado
porque la mayoría en el senado valentina
pues determina si va a tener el partido
republicano o el demócrata la por el
poder la potestad de aprobar el gabinete
de el nuevo presidente electo joe biden